how are you where are your placements
all been Haven and Chapel Haven okay
good so you're gonna see some kids and
adults today on some of our video clips
that will probably remind you of some
people you've seen not because they are
the people you've seen but because the
types of issues and behaviors are
demonstrating are relatively consistent
and give you a little caveat about what
we're gonna do for the next hour and a
half or so how do you guys handle
questions whatever they want good okay I
have two ground rules if you don't mind
the first one is if you have a question
don't wait okay just ask it because ten
other people in this room have the same
question they're shy the second thing is
I know you're doing some practice so
you've got some other clients you're
working with if you want to ask a
question about one of the people you're
working with I don't mind that but let's
save it till the whole thing is over and
I'll stick around for a little bit okay
I imagine you've got supervisors on the
sites where you are so you wouldn't
necessarily want to come to me with that
because I don't know your clients but if
you had something like that if you want
to ask you a question about somebody on
the videotapes I can certainly respond
to those if it looks like we're running
a little bit later on some of the
discussions and everything like that
then what I'm gonna do is probably hold
a couple of the videotapes but I'll show
them to you as soon as we finish okay
because they're kind of fun and what I
want to do is use the videotapes as a
way of giving you an example of what
we're talking about we're gonna we're
gonna spend pretty much all of this time
talking about what happens when you've
got behavioral issues with people with
autism and you may have heard this from
some of the other presenters but the
most important thing I can tell you
today and it's really the take-home
message is behaviors communication and
you're gonna spend 85% of your time on
the assessment side okay because with a
good assessment you will very clearly
inform your intervention practice and
with a poor assessment you may get lucky
or you may be completely off base and
you may end up either encouraging or
reinforcing the behavior you really
don't want to see or you might end up
doing some harm and when I say harm
we're talking about problems in learning
problems in behavior and every
it goes beyond that and alright there's
something that's not doing what it needs
to do maybe it goes that's the way it
goes today okay we're gonna start with a
little story and this is about a kid
that I worked with a number of years ago
I was called into a school system not up
here in Connecticut's when I worked down
in DC and I was I was asked to do some
consulting around this kid the kid had a
pretty important and problematic
behavior and it kind of went like this
he'd be in a regular classrooms in a
public school it's a guy with autism
he's about nine years old it's got
language he reads does some academics in
a learning center which is more or less
a special education environment with
some integration into the mainstream of
various points during the day now this
request for consultation is around
significant challenging behavior and it
goes like this
the guy is sitting at a table maybe like
one of these about half that size for
four students sitting around the table
they're all doing their seat work well
in the middle of something our fellow
here stands up grabs ahold of the table
screams the Rosenberg find-out flips the
table everything scatters tips it on
tips a table on top of the other kids so
the person who's who I'm working with
we're looking at this and we're thinking
all right well what's the best way to
think about this problem the guys name
isn't Rosenberg it has nothing to do
with Rosenberg's it has to do with
something else and we have the
opportunity to try to sort that out we
go through a process and the process is
really the one that I'm going to outline
for you this afternoon
including the treatment side of it but
the process is one of Investigation it's
one of asking why questions why would he
do this
under what circumstance what
precipitated it what was the what what
we call the setting events and the
antecedent conditions and when we think
about it this way it allows us to ask
questions posed responses based on
observable facts or data those are the
things that we as behavior analysts and
psychologists who are working in this
field you sort of live and die by this
when you work with significant
challenging behavior with people with
developmental disabilities
these I'm gonna use autism today as an
example but you could have an individual
who's got creative Shaw syndrome or
somebody who's got intellectual
disability by virtue of Down syndrome
any number of other situations you're
going to see some videos of kids who are
severely and profoundly typical who are
just typically developing toddlers - to
give you an illustration of some
important points the the good part of
this is that behavior has relatively in
many cases relatively clear-cut
contingencies what starts it what keeps
it going and our job as folks trying to
solve these issues is really to wrap
them up and understand what's going on
so we can help the kids or adults learn
to respond or behave in a somewhat
different way this could be a little
more socially appropriate than flipping
tables
screaming the Rosenberg find-out so as
we're doing our investigation with this
guy we ask a bunch of questions and we
talk to different people and we watch
and we observe over several days and we
see several examples of flipping the
tables it's not like a one-time deal
pretty much the same response every time
now because I'm anchored to this I can't
run around the room but what would
happen typically scream stand up scream
the Rosenberg find-out flip the table
run to the door but not go through it
stand at the threshold of an open door
and watch the chaos going on around them
so you can imagine you got kids jumping
around and you got teachers and teacher
aides are getting crazy he's kind of
sitting there taking it all in and a
couple seconds one of the adults in the
room comes over to him and says alright
Joey go sit down over there by the books
in the beanbag chair and just like calm
down that's the scenario so we see this
very consistent pattern of he's at the
table jumps up screams flips runs stops
somebody send him to the book area to
sit in the beanbag chair it's happened
six or eight times so we're looking at
this and we're saying wonder what that's
all about what are you thinking so far
what are you thinking so forth
what's going on here
he wants some kind of a reaction good
terrific now we talk about reaction from
whom anybody particularly come into mind
for you maybe the teachers sure it could
be the kids could just be a reaction
right we don't know yet but you're on
the right track because there was a
behavior and there's and there's an
effect we have we have something that
started in some way of having an effect
we look a little further and we started
asking ourselves questions what's he
doing at the table this is not happening
all day long he's not flipping tables
every time he sits down at the table to
do work so we watch him he reads he
answers questions he does math
worksheets and we start to watch the
work at the table and we notice there's
one particular time this is more likely
to occur we're gonna call that a high
probability sequence okay the time that
it's most likely to occur is when he has
a worksheet in front of them that has an
open-ended question okay now we have an
example close based and open-ended
questions a closed based question might
be like a multiple-choice question right
where the universe of possible responses
you know ABC and D they're defined for
you you don't have to say well I'm not
sure where to go with this because the
four choices are right in front of you
we call those closed based questions
open-ended questions would be like so
what are you gonna do today after you
finish with this class dot dot dot fill
in the blank write me seven sentences
about that all right it's up to you to
decide but it's also incumbent on you to
organize okay so you have to come up
with a gestalt and then you have to say
ah well probably gonna go have supper
with who where immediately or later I
gonna stop and do some work first you
have to put that all together
this guy had pretty reliable antecedent
events that included open-ended response
situations that had a written component
so if you had a teacher sitting next to
him saying so what just happened in the
story was that this this this or this no
problema if he had open-ended what would
you think would happen to the child if
the event didn't occur write it down
flip the table Rosenberg find-out to the
door to the beanbag
look at the books okay what do you
think's going on now it may well be to
escape from the work exactly it good
hypothesis and it's actually the one
we're working with to start he may be
saying I'm looking at this work not
going to do it one way to get out of
doing the work is to flip the table and
we're under the door very good I'm a
behavior analyst at the end of this
class I'm going to show you a graph of
response latencies yours how long it
takes you to answer the question when I
first asked you I'm just okay he's
getting away from this and he's zipping
to the door okay now there's something
else going on here and in it's subtle
but escaped from demand is certainly a
hypothesis that we want to test out here
but there's something else that's going
on because what else is he doing he's
hitting the door and then what is an
adult saying to him go to the beanbag
chair and it could be a reinforcer let's
make a distinction between rewards and
reinforcers okay it's just maybe a minor
one but in my book it's going to be a
fairly major one it could be a
reinforcer have you guys had any
background on the difference between
rewards and reinforcers so you know that
reinforcers do what increase the
probability of the behavior occurring in
the future okay that was an introvert
that's very close to a closed based
question okay and you've got it very
good so what we have with this is
somebody who says hey wow I get out of
this because I don't want to do it
anyway
and I got to go sit in a beanbag chair
and look at a book and I want you to
make a distinction for me if both of
them are possibly reinforcers what type
of reinforcers would books and beanbag
chairs be positive good I want you to be
a little dig a little deeper on that do
you get the same feedback do you get the
same neurological feedback from reading
a book that's sitting in a beanbag chair
does anybody here not set in a beanbag
chair life
okay good what's it like what's it feel
like to sit in the beanbag chair say
it's relaxing was it feel like now what
does it think like was it feel like
comfortable okay it's kind of mold to
your body okay kind of smooshes in can
you think of a difference between
sitting in a beanbag chair and being
smushed into that and having somebody
give really tight squeeze and a hug you
know what kind of sensory information
you're getting from that it's called
proprioception okay basically joint
compression or deep pressure the
information that goes into your joints
goes to your brain says I know where I
am physically in this environment I'm
sort of wrapped okay it's like when we
have little tiny babies who are very
dysregulated after they're born and even
when they're not dysregulated what do we
do with those blankets we swaddled them
exactly we wrapped them up tight you
know why we do that because babies have
a startle reflex that when they go like
this scares the daylights out of them so
if you swaddle them they don't get
scared they're much calmer
okay that's all these people walking
about babies and pupusas and kangaroo
babies and everything else like this
there's meaning today all right so what
we've got is a guy who's getting a
reinforcer at two levels read the book
sit in this really cool chair pretty big
payoff but for what good behavior bad
behavior problem behavior you bet you
know you're the kid you're seeing the
teacher walk over with the handouts
she's gonna put him on a table you take
a quick look you see it's open-ended
what are you thinking you're thinking I
know how to get out of here and I know
how to get what I want because they
consistently give me the beanbag chair
nut books I like the beanbag chair in
the books there's one very clear way to
say that to my teachers it is Rosenberg
find-out flip the table and they'll give
me my books so if I'm a person with
autism and I'm saying I'd like to look
at the books now one way that I can
communicate that clearly perhaps not
adaptively but clearly is do the
behavior that's problematic everybody
understands it
therein lies the problem okay that's the
problem that we confront so we start
talking about what people with autism
might do or people with developmental
disabilities might do what we're really
looking at is the purpose behind their
behavior we call that purpose function
okay and you're gonna hear me talk about
function functional analysis functional
assessment pretty much all afternoon we
talk about folks with with autism
spectrum disorders and behavioral issues
we have to remember first and foremost
if you have an autism spectrum disorder
it is a social learning disability yes
ma'am
right punishing him would not take away
the thing that was troubling him
initially that's right
okay how many of you guys are psychology
majors who's not what are you guys in
Spanish okay biology okay gotcha okay
biochem okay everybody in here wants to
help somebody right you want to help
them talk speak better Spanish and you
want to make them better biochemists or
whatever you guys do with your lives
you make all of us healthy which is a
good thing which in my case is a very
good idea here's the thing you all want
to help people so you have a natural
tendency to jump to an intervention
before you if before its time which is
exactly what you did and I'm not
faulting you for it because all of us
are gonna do that we're gonna say okay
what do we do you know what the answer
is at this point you don't you
understand it better so you don't make
mistakes now you asked a really good
question when you said giving this guy's
some sort of a punishment procedure is
not likely to address the trigger the
antecedent right of the of the behavior
itself so we could punish him until the
cows come home but every time he sees
that paper he's gonna have to think
maybe I'll take the punishment because
I'm really had it with his paper stuff
what if I told you that there are two
other important things we have to do
change the antecedent and change the
adult behavior and teach him a new
behavior now what is flipping the table
screaming the Rosenberg find-out saying
what's the communicative intent ladder
before that be who I don't want to do
this work you said it before I don't
want to do this paper maybe it's also
saying I want to go sit in the beanbag
chair and read the book let's just say
for argument's sake initially it's
saying I don't want to do this work or I
don't know how to do this work fair
enough are we good
tell me an alternative response that you
as that student could emit could do to
say I don't want to do it or I need help
what could you do that would be socially
acceptable that's exactly right
okay did you have some kind of a class
when you're a little kid to teach you
hand raising did you really where'd you
learn it did you pick it up in
kindergarten you probably did okay and
why are you using it now most of you
when you had a question raise your hand
why you're nice why do you use it
because it works it's functional it's
what we call a pivotal response I know
what hand raising means you raise your
hand I'm gonna say you have something
you want to ask because you need help or
you don't understand or you got to use
the restroom something but it's an
attention cue it's an attention signal
and I know what it means I didn't take a
class in hand raising any more than you
did but I did learn it by observation
modeling and reinforcement okay I didn't
learn it by punishment
I learned it because when I raised my
hand I got somebody's attention faster
than when I flipped the table
screaming the Rosenberg find-out when we
start talking communicative intent we
have to go to get to your question we
have to go back to what is he trying to
say to us that's why I said to you
behavior is communication he is saying
out of here need help
can't do it if he raised his hand
without flipping the table what would be
the most likely thing you as a teacher
would do
would you ignore him you're not sure
don't teach Spanish if you would ignore
him not good what's that you would walk
over you'd go allow him to solicit your
attention your your assistance and you
would do something about it now if you
did something and it made work easier
for him what's his payoff
I eat what's his reinforcer if you help
him with the work is it easier or harder
than if he does it himself it's easier
okay if it's easier that means there's
less effort on his part with greater
success you will do the things that are
easier for you to do and also have them
maintain high correct response rate
success okay you'll do that all right
organisms do that they go for what's
easy and what works best that's all we
have to work with if you take that
example pretty much everything we talked
about the rest of the afternoon is gonna
start to hang together we good with your
question okay this is a social learning
disability a lot of behavior in autism
and because I know you've heard a few
lectures before I got here you know that
the range of capacity in autism is
tremendous some of you are working at
Chapel Haven so you've got some
individuals who are to say that they're
high-functioning is an understatement
some of these folks you know wrote the
book on IQ and they can do things in
their heads that we can't conceive of on
the other hand they may do that with
absolutely no understanding that there's
a social engagement that goes on with
this that you have to participate in
some meaningful way to share what you
know and are doing with someone so they
want to do it back with you the social
learning disability and the
misunderstanding of social context is
one of the biggest problems that we deal
with an autism that affects the
behavioral issues the second thing is
and another concept I'm sure you've
heard is that folks with autism don't
necessarily know that you're thinking
the way you are they may be thinking you
think like they think now I know that
was a rather convoluted thing but I want
you to think of having to take someone's
perspective and what that requires you
to do okay it requires you to think
about how someone else is experiencing
something as opposed to your immediate
experience and the importance of that as
a core issue in the social disability in
the autism spectrum really can't be
understated so if we have someone who
says well what's wrong with flipping the
table and screaming the Rosenberg
find-out wow it's not exactly what you
see in school and then if I said to you
what's wrong with the Rosenberg find-out
as a phrase what would you say why is
that a bad communicative strategy
doesn't communicate anything about what
you want or need true enough it doesn't
well if I'm if I have autism and that's
my phrase works for me right mind
blindness is the person with autism
saying it works for me it must work for
you you read my mind you know my mind my
blindness is I don't know that you don't
okay the phrase the Rosenberg find-out
is a very specific type of social
communication problem is called a
neologism okay it's a word made up by
someone to mean something okay so we
have lots of neologisms in autism they
go all over the place all over the map
but the bottom line is the person with
autism is thinking you know what I'm
trying to say here and you as the
teacher you as the student sitting next
to him are saying I don't know what's
going on
this guy's wild okay this is dangerous
to be around here the third thing is
that executive functions are generally
compromised in the world of autism so if
you have somebody who has difficulty
looking at a situation in deciding
what's the most relevant piece of
information here you have somebody who
doesn't necessarily take experiences
from from the past that they've had and
apply them to a new situation in this
somewhat flexible or modified way if
somebody who doesn't scan the
environment for somebody who's being
successful and say I will just hang
around that successful person and I'll
do okay okay that's the problem of
executive functions and they're rampant
in autism the fourth thing is that we
have this tendency towards rigidity and
if you've done anything with Ben Haven
are you some of you guys going up to Ben
Haven and wallingford to the school okay
with with keron Alleyne
okay
and some of you or some of you going
over to the to the residence you've seen
some folks with autism who are a little
rigid here and there you know behavioral
rigidity certainly you've seen that with
some of the individuals at the chapel
Haven who are very capable you know
things have to be a certain way okay
that rigidity
that's not pest Enis that's like air
that's a necessity to organize oneself
to respond okay that's something that's
very important to the person now that
might lead you to think well fine if
that's what they need let's give it to
them but rigidity isn't very adaptive in
the environment because if you're rigid
in your access to the environment you
can only access highly predictable
environments which means you can only go
to the places that you really know and
understand you don't get out of your
orbit out of your environment and if you
think about what a lot of people with
autism do is they fail in novel
environments they could look really good
in familiar environments but they fail
in novel environments and and that
particular problems is called a lack of
fluency you can't use your skill in a
variety of novel settings and it doesn't
serve folks with autism very well when
we think about behavioral interventions
we absolutely positively wrap it around
learning and social environments for
assessment and for intervention
treatment planning development that
behavior has lots of purposes the stuff
on the left from aggression all the way
down to vocal and motor tics that's what
you're gonna call us about you're gonna
say I've got a kid he bites or I have a
kid and he flaps his fingers and he does
this or he kind of this is a great room
for this if you have autism you'd have a
field day in here perhaps because we got
verticals we got fluorescent lights I
can do all kinds of things and make
patterns with my hands I can make this
room very visually stimulating without
even talking to you guys and I could sit
here and do this and really get off on
it and enjoy it and not be thinking does
this group of students think I'm nuts do
they think that this is just not what a
professor does and not not only not
think it not care to know because I'm
more involved in getting this type of
visual sensory feedback that I'm looking
for
okay that's part of the problem we see
but we often get these requests are
these Rick these calls to consult or
solve the problem when people identify
the behavior in questions so they say
we've got aggression we have pike oh you
know a pike is ingesting in edibles
so people who eat cigarette butts not
chew on swallow okay or coins rocks
stones you know it's fairly dangerous
behavior we're not talking about people
who like to their shirt we're talking
about ingestion self-injury
non-compliance you know you name it
those behaviors are problematic and they
get in the way they're stigmatizing
they're dangerous they're minimally
they're annoying and when we've done
some research on looking at so when we
have behaviors where do they go we find
that for the majority of individuals
with autism spectrum disorders escape
from demands is the most likely function
purpose behind reason for the behavior
so we find that people will do behaviors
to get out of doing other things that
you want to do fair enough
we also find that when we look across a
whole and this is about we're talking
about a couple hundred individuals in
this particular sample of a study done a
number of years ago if you just take
access to tangibles okay which is I want
a certain thing and if you don't give it
to me I'm gonna have a fit okay you've
got almost 50 percent forty four and a
half percent of the individuals in this
particular survey their behavior was
maintained by triggered by wanting
access or wanting escaped I want what I
want and I don't want to do what you're
asking me to do okay that is a very
common finding in the world of autism we
do have people however who engage in
behavior problems to access social
attention they do it for purposes of
obtaining sensory feedback or what we
call stereo de pees and then there's a
lot of behavior that's multiplied
function we can't think about the
Rosenberg find-out that behavior was
actually multiple functioned okay you
said escape from the task and young lady
in the back said maybe he wanted the
access to the attention or the reading
of the book or sitting in the beanbag
chair perfectly reasonable this is
negative reinforcement
you're talking about positive
reinforcement now by the way why is
getting out of doing the dirty work with
the open-ended question negative
reinforcement and not punishment
have you guys tackled that yet who
drives a car whether you're here at
university or somewheres else well if
you have seatbelts what happens if you
don't put the seatbelt on what happens
you could turn the ignition on you don't
put the seatbelt on what the car dings
at you you have some sort of an audible
signal most of you okay that's good
you're driving cars that are post 1970
that's a good thing okay so you have a
noise that happens you like the noise do
any of you like the noise what do you
need to do to make the noise go away
sorry
put on your seat belt you got to click
it right okay what is the immersive
stimulus the noise what do you do to
terminate the aversive stimulus you put
the seat belt on is wearing your seat
belt considered a positive or a negative
behavior is it appropriate or not
appropriate okay so negative
reinforcement is terminating the versiv
stimulus
all right in order to get reinforcement
what's your reinforcement when you put
the seat belt on it stops exactly the
noise goes away so you're saying oh
thank god all I got to do is click my
seat belt to make this aversive
contingency go away so we've got is the
removal of an aversive contingency all
right that you have control over and you
do something good to do that and that's
a that's a good pro-social behavior but
it operates on the context of negative
reinforcement which is exactly what's
going on here
now the tricky little thing is as soon
as you do that this kid flips a table
and he runs over there and they tell him
to sit down in the chair we have two
things going on he's reinforced cuz he
doesn't have to do the work you tell him
to go sit down in the chair now he's
quiet everything's calm you the adults
are reinforced
okay they were very dangerous trap going
on here that people fall into all the
time it even has a term it's called the
negative reinforcement trap more on that
a little bit later but at the end of the
day if we don't analyze these individual
what we call contingencies you might say
don't flip the table I'm going to put
you in timeout which will not change
this behavior over the long term it'll
lead to symptoms substitution all kinds
of problems all kinds of consequences
you can have educational access that you
lose you can have social access that you
lose you can get into trouble with the
law you can you know break things and
people make you pay for them please
to what
when you say the word there you mean
folks with autism here got it
it makes perfect sense is that the
intent is that what you took from what I
said you got it okay everybody in this
room responds to negative reinforcement
contingencies okay and everybody in this
room seeks positive reinforcement
contingencies all right some of you
don't manage them well and sometimes
you're more negative and people leave
you alone and if you like being left
alone that's a really good strategy
except you won't have any friends after
a while on the other hand if you really
want to be around people and you're
crabby all the time you don't get what
you want the key difference in here the
one distinction I want to make is you
added something in which you may or may
not have intended to say in the same way
which is of lower intelligence don't
make an assumption about intelligence
when you talk about autism because
there's that there's a term that I'm
going to use with you and you may have
heard this before - multiple
intelligences I want you to think of
people with autism from the context of
multiple intelligences rather than a
global intelligence factor or something
like like G ok that we would say well
there is an IQ the world of autism is
far too variable for them it's much more
common to have somebody who's got
absolutely breathtaking visual
perceptual skills and can quote can see
something close their eyes and reproduce
a schematic of that like this but have
horrific ly bad verbal skills and can't
have a conversation okay and the
literature is full of individuals like
this so what I want us to be thinking
about is people with intelligences or
domains of intelligence and domains of
deficit okay rather than a global and I
think that it I don't know if you were a
chapel haven or at Ben Haven but if
you're a chapel Haven you're running
across from folks who are you know
working on six cylinders in some areas
and even if you're at Ben Haven with
some individuals who are very
significantly compromised you also know
that there are some some fellows there
and women there that can do things you
say how can that be the person can't
handle any situation that demands
flexibility they have no language a lot
of behavioral problems yet they can
still whatever they can do that's
exceptionally good really that's the
paradox of autism okay that's what makes
it so uniquely different than
intellectual disability in its most
straightforward form is the variability
and if you're somebody like me and you
know this is 36 years that I've been
I've been working with kids in the
autism spectrum and adults in the autism
spectrum that's the thing that makes me
get up every day it's the wow factor
it's like how'd you do that that's
really cool well to this we move to some
basic assumptions that build upon
something that you were saying which is
if behaviors communication then we also
recognize that behaviors a relationship
between the person and the environment
behavior doesn't occur in a vacuum and
when I talk about environment I'm not
just talking about physical environment
I could be talking about internal
environment anybody here had the flu yet
hope not did you couch okay in the early
part of your flu you guys had had the
flu did you go to class some days when
you were just starting to get sick were
you at the top of your game probably not
right because you're still feeling kind
of punky about you're not even sure why
you're not feeling good and then all the
sudden you get real sick okay then you
finally hopefully stop going to class
and got a little better maybe not
you could have an internal environment
illness is an environmental setting
called a setting event that can affect
your performance so if you had been
really doing well in a class and
studying and getting great grades on
tests and quizzes and you go sick and
take a test and you bomb have you become
dumb or is it your illness that's
interfering with your attention focus
and short-term working memory probably
the latter okay we call the illness a
setting event or an establishing
operation more on that later but it is
an important variable and if you don't
think of those variables you'll be
saying everything is outside its
peripheral to the person with autism
when we have some internal issues we
have people with neurocognitive deficits
they have right-brain left-brain
discrepancies we have people with poor
right hemisphere abilities and great
left hemisphere abilities and vice versa
if you know that you have a way of
thinking about how this person with
autism thinks you don't know that
you're throwing mud at the wall and
seeing what sticks you're hoping you can
figure it out so as we gather this kind
of information the more we get the
better we are if you're going to
intervene you address the variables that
are functional to the
which is why in the situation you
described we got a guy who's trying to
escape from a demand and we say fine you
want to escape I'm giving you time out
now I want you to put yourself in the
place of the person with autism in that
situation right you don't want to do
this you get upset you say I don't want
to do it you misbehave and I say fine
time out for you what have I just done
really come on were you happy to get the
time out what were you not so happy yeah
why you were happy why because you don't
want to do it anyway so what did I
functionally what did i do functionally
for you by giving you time out I gave
you an escape I run the risk that I just
gave you a functional reinforcer don't I
okay because it increases the likelihood
that you're gonna try to get out of
doing the work in the same way because
you're gonna get the time out so we have
someone who doesn't miss behavior we say
fine time out for you and a person's
going yes or they understand me the
communication works for this those are
the prêt of the pitfalls that we're
really trying to stay on top of because
happens regularly okay
let's hope for the best
I should make this work okay now this is
really the basics of what we're talking
about I want you to watch
you see Jamie
what's going on
what's the problem what's the target
behavior what's the problem behavior
that the child is doing the problem
behavior what is it yeah nobody's ever
seen this before right you've never seen
a tantrum okay
come to my house okay we have tantrum
behavior what is the learning
contingency that is maintaining that
tantrum
sorry he gets to stay on the camera you
think it's being on camera okay well
he's getting adult attention in the form
of for him he perceives positive tension
negative tension probably positive
attention it's positive reinforcement
alright so positive reinforcement
through social attention here right and
what this little guy is thinking is hey
whenever I see these people if I fall on
the floor this is gonna work fair enough
you watched about seven sequences I can
show you twelve more if you want to see
them because it goes on for a little
while now at the end of the class
there's going to be a little jar over
here there's I want you to put spare
change in it because it's for his
therapy fund because this kid's gonna
need it when he's older because he's
basically for infinity he's on on
YouTube here this is a very
straightforward example of problem
behavior maintained by social attention
when we as clinicians are looking to
understand problem behavior we say what
happens after the problem behavior to
increase the likelihood of its future
occurrence and what is setting the stage
for it now what if I said this kid is
super tired versus just got up from his
nap and is really well rested and he's
well fed and he's pretty robust what if
I told you that in this situation the
kid is super super tired
what would part of your intervention
include
letting the poor little guy have a nap
right alright but what if I said to you
not tired he's not hungry he's got
access to all kinds of good stuff
then what would part of your
intervention include or not include the
naps right if we want to change this
behavior what is one of the things we
have to do we have to change the
relationship between winning tantrums
and when he does or doesn't get
attention okay that is a basic it's a
basic intervention strategy here okay so
that's one of the things that we're
gonna be thinking about when we look at
behavioral assessment and treatment this
is not a linear process it's really a
circular process that never ends until
you decide that you have a replacement
behavior that's accessible to the child
or the adult with autism and it's fluent
meaning it can be used in a variety of
novel situations when you assess you get
information you develop a treatment plan
you go ahead and do the intervention
plan you treat and then finally you move
to an evaluation phase and the
evaluation gives you information that
reinforcement when you're reinforcements
you're continuously changing what's
going on now you can imagine that in the
case of that little guy we change one
thing what if we had what if I said to
the parents all right I want you to put
this behavior on extinction no attention
whatsoever from what you know about
basic principles of extinction
what is that behavior likely to do in
the beginning exactly why is it gonna
get worse and what do we call it we call
it an extinction first why is it going
to get worst think like the kid don't
think like an adult think like an 18
month old kid hey hey didn't you hear my
scream these poor people they must be
doing something else
I'm gonna ramp it up six or seven
notches then they'll really pay
attention to me okay that's kid think
that's the way these things work that's
why extinction births work all right
what's the worst thing you deal with an
extinction burst behavior is climbing
what's the worst thing you do give
attention as it's climbing you know why
you just reinforced
because the kids saying all right the
little stuff it doesn't get what I want
the big stuff works the next time I'm
going right for the top okay kids are
smart way smarter than we are so that's
what's going to happen with it if you
think about this as you're going through
this rubric for figure it out develop a
treatment evaluate the treatment
Riaan form your assessment and treatment
plan as you go you'll be getting the
right idea when we do behavioral
assessment we do behavioral assessment
for three reasons we want to predict
what's going on as we intervene we want
to be able to say all right I know
what's going on I have a pretty good
plan but I want to inform my ongoing
intervention that's that that circular
loop of new information adds to my
thinking about my treatment plan and its
effect and we want to provide this
information so we can make readjustments
we then want to be able to do a
summative evaluation in our behavioral
assessment formula which says I
understand what happened now there's
good reasons for having a summative
assessment even when the problem is now
gone particularly in autism because we
can have behaviors that change form but
retain function let me explain what that
means let's say instead of flipping the
tables I engage in self-injury okay and
I slap myself in the face okay and I
slap myself in the face and I slap
myself in the face and you get rid of
face slapping but now what I'm doing is
I'm biting my wrist and I'm biting my
wrist and then you get rid of that one
and then I'm getting it to property
destruction okay that kind of a sequence
of substituting an alternative form
happens when we don't address the
function so if I don't get at the very
basic fact that this guy in the
Rosenberg find-out cannot do open-ended
graphomotor tasks if I don't get at that
problem I will likely have new behaviors
that substitute for flipping the table
and screaming the Rosenberg find-out
I'll get something else
all right however if I intervene at the
level of the complexity or the the
processing demand of the problem itself
I will remove the reason for those
behaviors
make sense that's behavioral assessment
of treatment thinking about what causes
it
altering the contingencies so the
behavior no longer is functional there's
no reason to scream the Rosenberg
find-out works not hard or if works hard
to raise my hand you help me and I say
whoa that worked I raise my hand when I
need help the guy comes over okay that's
a lot easier than running around the
room and having people upset with you
well we do behavioral assessment and
treatment we're going to first think of
changing the environment okay we look at
the target behavior we say hmm got this
guy sitting at a big table with four
other kids for the students
what's one environmental modification I
can make just to the physical
environment what comes to mind quickly
for kids at the table what I work at his
own desk I could reduce the the crowding
okay from anybody who's done any basic
animal research what happens with
crowding what does it generally do to
arousal rates what does it generally do
to stereotypic responses it ramps them
up right okay and we for that matter it
also increases cortisol levels so you've
got poor response sets you got poor
adaptive responses in highly crowded
situations now most of us would say well
for kids at a big table not so crowded
but what if you are overstimulated by
physical movement and you see people
moving and you watch people move and it
distracts you from your task and you
can't get back on to your task because
people are moving around and it's an
unpredictable visual field for you there
is a problem that could be an aversive
event in autism might not be for you or
me but it could be for someone in autism
the second thing that you do is you
manipulate contingencies now the
contingencies we talked about in this
particular case are escape from demand
and positive reinforcement so we want to
do something to tinker with those we
want to change the escape consequence
all right and we want to turn the escape
consequence into a positive behavior
that gets what he needs which might be
assistance when he raises his hand
as opposed to no assistance and return
to the work when he flips the table
because right now flip the table means
work is gone right that's what you said
the reinforcing contingency was before
and you're absolutely right so now we
want to say flip the table you do the
work again instead of flip the table the
work goes away that's reversing a
contingency we also want to say raise
your hand and help you with the work and
make it easier that's adding a positive
contingency for a more adaptive and I
would say adaptive and functional
behavior we teach a functionally
equivalent alternative response you
identified what it was you said raise
his hand that's a very common one to use
and then finally we want to teach a
behavior that will address long term
needs and the reason I use the Rosenberg
find-out is it basically helps us wrap
all this up because here you guys are
right in your you know 13th 14th 15th
year of schooling and you still remember
how to raise your hands okay and
sometime you're gonna be working
someplace in a large meeting as a
professional and you're gonna raise your
hand hand raising to solicit attention
or assistance has longitudinal value and
in this culture most cultures many
cultures it's a socially acceptable way
of doing it most people are gonna pay
attention to you they give you attention
you're reinforced for hand raising the
natural consequences are fairly evident
now skip what's written because there's
a lot of 50-cent words in here here's
the basic concept you guys had the flow
you didn't feel so good alright maybe
some of you are sitting here saying I
don't have lunch today
alright I'm really having a hard time
paying attention or I not only had lunch
I have four desserts and I'm about to
hit a hypoglycemic low and it's going to
get ugly
all right that is a setting event
alright it is not an immediate trigger
stimulus it's not the immediate
antecedent it is what occurs before that
that sets the stage okay for the
likelihood that reinforcement will occur
or the likelihood that punishment will
occur and that's why we call it a
motivating operation because it it
establishes or it sets the stage for the
next operation it could be reinforcing
or punishing operation we say operation
we're basically using this
where does contingency here the easy
ones we think about her so how you
feeling are you hungry are you tired you
know have you had the wrong foods to eat
some of you guys had eight cups of
coffee today and some of you had maybe
none all right and your caffeine levels
are a little better Jamie and I were
talking before I just came back from
working in Italy and where we have three
projects going on and one of the things
I get to do in Italy is I get to drink
espresso the way you're supposed to
drink espresso but I don't drink coffee
americano we don't drink you know big
cup of coffee basically I'm doing shots
but I'm somebody who really likes coffee
a lot not a little a lot and I drink a
lot of espresso and it doesn't affect me
to have 1215 espressos a day it's kind
of an interesting thing but if I were to
have the equivalent amount of caffeine
and coffee here I'd be non-functional I
think it's I think it's a volume and
this short burst that goes through I
just sort of keep on a constant fuel
cycle with it
hey for better for worse at him I could
show you this exact same lecture done on
15 espressos in front of a you know an
audience of 300 people in Italy with
simultaneous translation I probably
wouldn't be talking any differently it's
just one of those things but the reality
is that some of these things set the
stage for better or poorer performance
and they are their internal events okay
some of them are external events some of
you guys working at Ben Haven have
clients that you work with who have
schedules of their activities right
picture schedules no okay all right
let's say that you know you're working
are you in a classroom you're in the
residence but there's a schedule and
residence for activities right let's
just say you go in there and you say hey
you know what I'm smart I'm in luck
Euler biology what are you in what's
your field
biochem alright I'm in biochem I know
more than these psychology geeks are
doing it's autism stuff we're doing away
with the schedules okay and behaviors go
off the wall now what's the relationship
between schedules and behaviors going
off the wall for a bunch of people with
autism
why would they have anxiety what does
the schedule give them you're right on
the mark here what does it give them
mm-hmm a sense of control and I don't
mean coercive control or manipulative
control but sort of knowing what's next
let's say structure routine
predictability schedules give you that
okay some of you people have PDAs you've
got other kinds of things I'm more basic
I have lift and I make lists if any of
you make lists nobody here do you that
12-step program so some of you make
lists okay what do you do with your
lists when you finish stuff why do you
cross them off it because it feels good
okay good that's well Lisa's honesty
here good and now you cross them off
because it feels good you cross it off
because you've finished it okay it's not
about the work just how I feel okay so
you cross it off because you've finished
it and as your list gets crossed off
what are you doing you're completing
your tasks as the number of cross offs
increases and the uncrossed off items
decreases what do we call that progress
right we call it moot it's a progression
of time and tasks if you have a schedule
for a person with autism and they're
starting here on the schedule they're
working their way down and as they
complete an activity they take the
picture away or the words a way that
that identify that particular task
they're doing exactly the same thing now
I don't want any hands for this but some
of you guys when you make these lists
hey cuz you're gonna cross things off so
you can feel good about it you put
things on the list you've already done
so you cross them off right away okay
there's about quarter of you and here to
do that it's not because you're bad
people it's because you just you just
need a lot more reinforcement to
motivate yourself and it's really okay
to do that you have my permission to do
that when you have a behavior issue a
lot of times people say well what was
the immediate trigger you'll only get so
far if you think of those immediate
triggers you have to move up a level to
ask
what's the physical context think
crowding what's the social context think
sarcasm tell you about that in just a
second
what's the biological context think
illness okay so let's see we'll pick
somebody out in here I haven't picked on
yet lady in the back he's really typing
madly on there I could say because you
have a pendant on this shaped like a
heart I could say Wow beautiful pendant
right or I could go beautiful pendant
same words what differs
tone good what else effect good what
else don't think words think face
yeah.well facial expression sure one was
a little friendlier one was little non
so friendlier okay what's the most
important piece of information the words
no not the words because the words are
the same toned facial expression effect
volume voice all of that comes together
as social context to say and one he was
giving a compliment than the other maybe
he was being sarcastic
wouldn't that be rude for some guy
you've never seen before to walk into
your class and be sarcastic about your
pendant what you might go on to thinking
all kinds of things about what a not
nice or nice person I might be in other
situations depending on how I give you
either one of those two responses
that's context now that informs any of
these and you need to know what these
are or you're gonna short yourself on
understanding this you need the
background so if you think about what's
going on in the macro and we think about
this as more macro and now what's going
on in the micro the immediate trigger
that sets it off you have a better
understanding of the experience of the
person with an autism spectrum disorder
in that behavioral moment now in
behavioral assessment we do four things
I'm going to tell you about them that
I'm going to go through them we're gonna
have some videos as we go through these
two an ecological assessment a
motivational assessment reinforcer and
then a functional assessment or
functional analysis is anybody in here
has anybody in here been involved in
doing functional analysis before as in a
contingency reversal or came from a
behavior behavioral background anywheres
else or is moving towards an OK or
worked with little autistic kids where
you did a BA or anything along those
lines
no you did okay as a home tutor
the summer camp okay functional
assessment functional analysis are some
of the things that we get really
involved with understand learning as
well as behavioral issues we talk about
ecological assessment worth I want you
to think macro what's the big picture
telling us so we do several things we
look at the physical environment we say
what in this physical environment might
set this stage with the Rosenberg
find-out we said where's the kids
sitting is it crowded is it noisy what
if I told you that instead of the paper
that I brought to the kid that was
open-ended triggering him it was his
classmate who hums coming into the room
and sitting next to him and he's
constantly humming and that's the
trigger okay whenever he hears the hum
he flips a table to be a different
intervention one of the interventions
that you might suggest would be how
about we move the humming guy away from
the guy who's flipping the tables or
what else could you do to the guy who
has to listen to the hum to soften the
impact of the hump huh yeah you're buds
we're headphones or something that kind
of puts white noise behind it drowns it
down okay the next thing we look at her
antecedent behavior consequence just
called ABCs of behavior okay and we're
looking to see does the behavior have a
reliable or predictable set of things
that almost always trigger it does a
behavior itself look fairly consistent
in its presentation and what are the
typical consequences that occur when we
do an ecological assessment we often
find that there are very reliable
antecedents and very reliable
consequences okay because behavior
believe it or not it's fairly
predictable most people do things the
same way over and over again they just
don't think about that the next thing we
do is look at the learning environment
and in the case of the Rosenberg
find-out kid that learning environment
involved a cognitive task of being able
to process open-ended information
construct a rubric for producing a
graphomotor response fairly complex if
you think about it in those terms for
this guy he may have been able to read
it and talk it but not write it if you
work with somebody with Asperger's
syndrome the problem of being able to
speak an amazingly coherent paragraph
but not right more than three sentences
would not surprise a lot of us okay
because in Asperger's syndrome a
graphomotor deficit could be part of a
right hemisphere inefficiency is a very
common thing to have happen and then
finally a temporal analysis has to do
with when is this occur early in the day
right after lunch right before lunch
only on Mondays okay only on Wednesday
mornings but never any other day of the
week and then you go back and you do a
little looking and you find out Wow mom
and dad don't live together no mom and
dad do live together there's got an
intact family but every Tuesday night he
goes and stays with nanny and Grampy and
nanny and grandpa our nannies and
grandpa's and they do whatever he wants
no contingencies you know it's free for
all the kid comes in the next morning
thinking get whatever I want I just did
all right and so what we have now is the
infamous nanny and Grampy interventions
which have probably more to do with
fixing this behavior than working on the
kid okay well we have a motivational
assessment we're asking questions about
what makes this behavior go what makes
it happen we have several things we
could think about the first that we
described is positive reinforcement
it can be social attention or stuff you
are reinforced by what I give you
you really like these little kind of
neat pointers and I give it to you and
then you play with it and you shine it
at people and do things like that that's
a positive reinforcer for material
reinforcer social attention however is
all about us you do things and I respond
to you and you do more of that and I
respond more to you okay escape
avoidance of demands is exactly what he
did with the written work reinforcer
loss is really a subset of this one I
separated for a very important reason
because behavior that is maintained by
losing access is what we're talking
about so you're playing your Nintendo DS
and you haven't hit the level yet and if
you turn it off or close it up you're
going to lose all your points that's far
right that's what my seven-year-old
tells me he says I can't turn it off and
go start my homework because I'm between
levels and since I can't do the DS I
know I'm getting scams but I don't know
how to beat this problem I know he's I
know he really can to stop this and save
it
but it's uh it's a trick you play on
your parents and they they lose all the
time the loss of access to something
that you like a material thing that you
like or you say I want it and I say not
now you have to wait you can't have it
now that's a problem that is is about
reinforcer loss the next one has to do
with sensory consequences reinforcement
or negative reinforcement sensory
reinforcement is I am much more
interested in the way this looks I'm
talking to you
and I will do this for a really long
time doesn't make any difference to me
what you think what I think I like this
it's giving me what kind of feedback let
me just say what I'm doing I'm looking
through my fingers and I'm looking at
that light and I'm going like this what
kind of feedback am I getting visual
good what type of visual feedback
remember fingers to life I give you I'm
gonna give you a clue if I look at my
fingers if I focus on my fingers
something different happens to the
background with the light but if I focus
on the light I have eight fingers I'm
getting a what a little figure-ground
Distortion okay you're with me try it
I'm the guy on YouTube you're not all
right this is my life all right you can
do this in the privacy of your own home
I lied you're all on YouTube but it's
going to go up in about a month so you
do this and I'm getting a figure-ground
distortion that's kind of close to 3d
isn't it
right you see things in different
dimensions stereoscope is if you're a
five-year-old and you're on the
playground and you're doing this against
the trees or against the leaves that are
blowing on the trees what do you think
other five girls are gonna do with you
typical five-year-olds you're gonna run
up to you and say wow how can I do that
to you don't think
they might make fun of you they might
avoid you if they're five and they're
nice maybe they just won't even play
with you they'll just say mm-hmm you
know by the time you get into seventh
grade that's when they make fun of you
now what can I go buy at a store right
now Toys R Us KB Toys what can i buy at
a store that has been around for 30
years that provides really good
figure-ground feedback that has context
that other children would want to play
with if you had it a kaleidoscope
perfect what else the viewfinder thing
yeah that's exactly right and it's yes
it it's a you know I'm talking about
sorry a viewmaster thank you I lost it
for a second on there a view masters
it's what you're thinking about and I go
and buy you know Disney Princess little
discs and I put it in there and all the
other little kids who like Disney
Princesses come over and they want to
look at it I do this i generate
avoidance behaviors I do a viewmaster
with an interesting disc in it and I
generate approach behaviors for the kid
on the spectrum both stimuli are
providing similar visual perceptual
feedback part of the intervention is
often to understand what's maintaining
the behavior at that level at the
sensory level and saying can I come up
with a better alternative that will
access approach behaviors okay part of
your intervention is to bring them to
the child and still get the child things
that they're looking for classical
conditioning certainly happens think
fears and phobias and organic factors
certainly occur we got a little guy
right now who we just finished the sleep
study actually down here and here's
obstructive sleep apnea okay but nobody
was thinking about that they were just
thinking about this little kid who was
tantruming wildly problem was he was
having so many episodes of obstructive
sleep apnea did he had no REM sleep he
had he would drop into REM he he would
awake he would snort and awaken and he'd
pop right back up again and he basically
couldn't recharge his batteries and this
was going on for years and he was a very
unhappy little boy
okay and you know what the intervention
was tonsils and adenoids okay and the
the doc said we got a kid with
obstructive sleep apnea he's got tonsils
the size of oranges and let's make those
go away and lo and behold you have a
physical intervention for a physical
problem it affects behavioral output you
don't want to forget the fact that human
beings sometimes have these events
physical events that get in the way we
look at assessing stimulus preferences
which is reinforced for assessment
that's something we were doing when I
was showing you the hand flapping
episode and you came up with an
alternative which was get him a
viewmaster again I'm a kaleidoscope when
you think of stimulus preferences you
say what is the information the person
is getting to guide what they're getting
afterwards reinforces it you pick have
to be common and be available right is
it they're not very exotic they're not
going to be in the natural environment
so I may be able to teach you guys in
this class how to do something because I
have something that you can't get
anywhere else so by virtue of novelty I
shape your behavior but if it doesn't
work anywhere else it's not going to
generalize the behavior
there'll be no fluency reinforcers have
to be functional meaning they work they
increase behavior and they really need
to be age-appropriate now functional
analysis is the process of answering the
question in an empirical way why does
this behavior happen okay that's what
this is all about what I'm going to do
is I'm going to show you the four FA
vignettes at the end okay if you want to
stay for them that's okay if you don't I
understand that too they're useful to
the extent that they give you a real
life in clinic observation of how we do
it and what the child's response is to
that but what do we get when we do a
functional analysis well we find out
with empirical validation this is
essentially having controlled conditions
it's a little experiment actually it's
four little experiments you have a
controlled condition where you do
something and get the response from the
child or you don't do something and you
see what the response from the child is
okay so I look at this child with the
Rosenberg find-out behavior and I say I
don't allow him to escape what happens
to the problem behavior up through the
ceiling in other words I keep saying
nope just keep working on this worksheet
or as soon as he starts to get fidgety I
say hey don't worry about the worksheet
go take a break
behavior ramps right back down again on
off on off I watch the behavior rise and
fall rise and fall
what I'm doing is experimentally
validating the hypothesis the second
thing we do is we find out what
consequences you're maintaining we're
able to look at what we call chains of
behavior okay now I'm gonna tell you
what the chain was for this guy because
he'd be sitting in his chair be working
kind of nicely I bring his work sheet
over put it down in front of him start
to see him fidget a little agitation
kind of like this pushing the paper away
pop okay scream jump run if I want to
intervene at an early point in the
behavioural chain where do I go at what
point do I intervene so I wait for him
to scream and jump
maybe when I saw him start to agitate
okay once the paper was down could be
having a good day he might do his fine
but if I start to see the agitation and
I'm saying to myself predictably
reliably that agitation is a precursor
to the behavior blowing up and I've
documented that and how do i do that
i'll document out with an ABC analysis
then i say okay now I know where I'm
going with this if I intervene here with
assistance before he blows up I'm able
to capture the behavior respond to his
need before he has exhibited a problem
behavior that I didn't have to respond
to for safety reasons okay we have high
and low probability situations that we
find out when we do a functional
assessment we say when is it behavior
most likely to occur winds at least
likely to occur we look for functionally
equivalent behavior what's a thing we
can teach them to do that gets the same
communicative payoff but it's more
adaptive and successful raise your hand
is more adaptive than flipping tables
these are the conditions in a functional
analysis and you'll see four of these
conditions when when I show you the
tapes a little bit later we've got a
time when there's nothing going on we
don't do anything to you there's no
consequence for your behavior we have a
situation where the kids playing by
themselves the kid in engages in the
problem behavior right and the adult
responds to it
oh don't worry it's okay don't don't be
concerned but for appropriate behavior
we don't do anything we only respond
with social attention to the problem
behavior in this situation we get the
problem behavior we give them something
so the kids trying to get something we
put all the fun stuff out of reach the
kid says I want it the kid starts having
a tantrum we say oh here you go
and you give it to them you let me play
with it for 30 seconds you take it away
you put it back up there the behavior
ramps up again you say okay here you go
you give it back to him you manipulate
his behavior with access to materials
and then later we're able to compare
does it get higher or lower when it's
social attention versus materials see
where this is going we're able to
experimental evaluate in about two
minutes for each of these
times two or three so we're talking
about what 5 times 2 1 2 3 4 5 times 2
is 10 times 3 30 minutes we can have a
three-part experimental validation of
the effect of our attention escaped
on-demand
materials or nothing at all the last
couple conditions have to do with does
the behavior occur when there are no
consequences going on so this one down
here is designed to elicit stereotypy if
it's going to occur in other words he
doesn't care about the material or you
this one up here is essentially a
baseline condition where it's this
replay okay okay we're gonna move past
that for a second you can do several
things to get this information you can
look at comments people make you can
review records you can have interviews
you can do some fairly formal structured
things there are several we use they're
available commercially they're short and
sweet they're all based on Likert scales
you know never happens always happens
five points with some degree of actually
a very good degree of inter-rater
reliability and validity for each of
these the motivation assessment scale on
the functional analysis screening tool
the MAS and the fast are the two most
common ones used okay they have each 20
questions you circle the items the items
are loaded for behavior that occurs
because of attention versus escape from
demand so for example on both of them
there's a very similar question does
this behavior occur in order to get your
attention or does this behavior occur
when you're in the room with other
people and you're talking to the other
people not the target child and if you
circle always you're beginning to load
towards social attention alternatively
there might be questions that say does
this behavior occur when the child's
doing some you give the child something
difficult to do and won't take it away
okay which is escape from demand you
have a number of questions for each of
these and they're loaded up into a
little scoring algorithm and they give
you hypotheses they don't tell you the
answer now why don't they tell you the
answer how are you gathering this
information
direct observation or talking to people
talking to people there's no direct
observation here one of the things that
we don't want to do is limit our
assessment to talking to people who want
to watch see and observe when we get to
a descriptive analysis we're doing the
watch see and observe an ABC analysis
that I mentioned to a little earlier
something called a scatter plot and I'll
show you both in a second and then we
can do direct observation so if I was
doing direct observation in this room of
people who are looking at the screen I
could be watching the clock in the back
and I could say whenever the clock hits
one of the numbers in other words would
be a five-second interval I'm talking to
you guys I look at the clock and as soon
as it hits I look around and I say are
you writing or not
all right mister are you looking at the
board or not and I just put a little
plus or minus and then it hits the next
number I take a look at you for the
intervening five seconds I don't care
what you do but on that five-second mark
I will watch to see for the occurrence
or the non occurrence of your behavior
that's what we call a time sample all
right and it's one of several different
ways of gathering objective information
we then aggregate to form some sort of a
behavioral profile we won't spend a lot
of time on this or the next one because
I think they're fairly self-evident when
you have what's called an ABC analysis
you see the a what happened before you
see the B for the behavior itself and
the C for the consequence and a little
description down the bottom when you
have an ABC analysis you are taking one
real time event and writing it down so
one flip of the table with the Rosenberg
find-out right here we say the kid was
sitting at the table doing his thing he
screamed the Rosenberg find-out flip the
table ran to the door what were the
antecedents well time of day who he was
with what the date was he's sitting at
the table it's after lunch I bring over
the the Halloween worksheet and say what
are you gonna be for Halloween and he's
got to fill it out and write me five
sentences about that flips a table then
what do we do what do we do we tell him
go sit down on the beanbag chair what
does he do he gets quiet
we do ten of these then we look for
patterns if we do ten of these and look
for patterns we're going to find
patterns most likely in the antecedents
and in the consequences Jamie I think
this is not some time just have a hard
time shooting antecedents and
consequences are going to give us
pattern if you had to choose should you
intervene at the antecedent level or the
consequent level which one would you
choose first what do you think yeah
why at the end of same level why you'll
get it before it happens right sure
it's a good idea to intervene where you
can at the antecedent level so you don't
have to deal with consequent responses
now recognize of course that this is
human nature and there's FAL ability
involved all over the place
but you do want to be able to get to the
behavior before it happens and maybe get
to the early part of that chain like the
fidgeting we were talking about okay a
scatterplot is nothing more than pulling
information on a time series so when
this behavior occurs by day by block of
hours here instead of hours on this side
I could have activities but all we're
doing is putting a tick mark on here
nothing more than a check okay we're
looking for aggregated volumes of
behavioral events when we do an FBA we
gather all this information we pull it
together in a way that has some
coherence and we do that so that we can
say what's making sense now there's a
downside to this too because it's fairly
time consuming you may accidentally or
intentionally reinforce problem behavior
because remember if the behavior is - in
the functional analysis if the behavior
is to gain escape and you don't allow
escape you will increase the behavior
alright you make a judgment as to
whether that's a safe thing to do or not
there's training demands because you
have to be very valid and very reliable
with this but you will experimentally
confirm or disconfirm a hypothesis that
is the power of doing a functional
analysis and I'll tell you at our clinic
our Center we have a specific clinic for
the assessment and treatment of severe
challenging behavior we don't do
functional analyses on a regular basis
we do them for as it were the the worst
of the worst behaviors we'll do a
functional assessment which is basically
to say let's get the hypothesis and test
it in situ in real life all right it's a
lot easier to do in a school it's a lot
easier to convince people that it's a
reasonable place to go but what you'll
be able to do with a functional analysis
is to demonstrate with a fair degree of
reliability and validity what's going on
now you get all this information 85% of
your work and now you've got to do
something with it so you have to link
your interventions into a treatment plan
and the reason I show you this
this particular slide is just to
emphasize that for the particular
function you have a particular treatment
plan and you may have two or three of
these you may have a behavior that's as
in the case I gave you there's both
escape and access to positive
reinforcement operating and you've got
to have two integrated components of the
treatment plan so you have to be
thinking ahead to know how do they work
together when you do this and I guess
there's really three take-home messages
right first ones that behaviors
functional the second one is
communication the third one is when
you're doing behavior management you are
really doing teaching you have to teach
an alternative if you don't teach an
alternative you're leaving the client
with nothing
okay if you make behavior go away in a
practical sense you're saying to the
person with autism figure it out on your
own figure out what to do next that's a
social learning disability they're not
likely to pick the right social behavior
to demonstrate for you if it's based on
function not form what it allows us to
do is to say we have particular skill
sets that may be linked together
different behaviors may be linked
together by function we have general
rules for intervention we consider the
first is function is preeminent the
second is what's called the fair pair
rule which means if you take one away
you put one back you always replace if I
teach you not to flip tables I must
teach you what to do instead and the
third thing is and any of you who work
with kids or have work with kids in the
past if you keep people busy and happily
engaged you'll have fewer behavior
problems so as long as we think ahead to
functional engagement replacement skills
that we teach and looking at the
functional application of those skills
so we can evaluate them effectively
we're in good shape if you have
communication skill teaching strategies
social teaching programs a behavior
support plan is integrated with that as
you were suggesting in the back when I
talked to you about the schedules
routine structure predictability order
control those are elements of stability
for a person with autism the more we
provide each of those in the person's
experience
the more the more appropriate behavior
we're gonna see but we're also going to
see more likely demonstration of
behaviors that have been taught so if we
teach someone schedules guide your day
transitions happen but we can we can
describe them visually on a schedule
when you've got a schedule you can
handle the transition that's one of the
things that we can do for person with
autism that that makes for lower arousal
rates you'll call it lower anxiety I'll
call it lower arousal the same concept
is going on here
conversely when we have a breakdown
instructor routine predictability order
or control we're likely to see behavior
problems so if I said to you we've just
had a breakdown in all those things and
now we've got this behavior going on
what's one of your first thoughts about
intervention what can you do to try to
bring behavior back to a better form you
could increase the structure
predictability routine control order of
the clients experience to simply bring
them back to what they expect bring them
back to what's predictable if we look at
adult behavior in the example I gave you
a little earlier with sarcasm if we look
at the adult behavior and say is it
consistent or not we often see the
chinks in the armor of problem behavior
that we create not the client creates
that we create thing we've got a guy
that we're working with right now who
has some very serious aggressions and
property destruction he's little he's
nine years old but one of the reasons he
does is he works in a room if you guys
can see the roof that little space in
the back it's smaller than that and it
has shelves and cabinets in it and it's
a little nine-year-old kid with two
adults in the room that size okay talk
about crowding has no natural light has
only fluorescent light and he can't get
out the door okay so we've got big
behavior problems going on in this kid's
life right there and one of the things
that we have to recognize is some of the
circumstances that the program he's in
may have created for him ramp up the
likelihood of that behavior he simply
can't move all right
he has no way out of them we sometimes
teach people various kinds of strategies
to compensate or to move beyond the
behavior which involves self-management
sometimes relaxation strategies
sometimes what we're going to call it
personal timeout now as we think about
our intervention plans we are
necessarily going to think about four
things we have to change the
communication we have to change what the
client says and does all right and how
they do it so it works better
that's called functional communication
training and we're going to teach a
better better response that responses
you suggest it was going to be hand
raising instead of flipping tables the
second thing we're going to do is we're
going to teach the replacement skill
remember the fair pair rule if you have
a new skill you want to teach you have
to use reinforcement strategies to build
that skill so you're going to teach the
child or the adult to do something
different that more likely elicits the
response that they want you're going to
modify the conditions around the
behavior if they're tired you give them
sleep if they're hungry they get they
have something to eat or perhaps it's
crowded
perhaps there's no schedule to follow
perhaps there's no other way of them
knowing what's coming next and you
address that as an antecedent condition
and then finally we recognize that there
going to be consequences because not all
behavior can be highly predictable in
anyone's life and we recognize that our
consequence strategies have to be highly
highly socially valid meaning that they
must be accepted by the consumers in the
environment and by the consumers we
don't just talk about teachers or
parents we talk about other people in
the environment the social environment
of a school a community a neighborhood
whether this particular behavior itself
is considered aberrant whether the
intervention strategy is considered
acceptable and whether the outcomes we
seek to achieve are considered socially
acceptable socially valid we have to use
the least restrictive interventions as
can be used because to euphemistically
you know kill a fly with a cannon it's
kind of pointless but you can have very
heavy-handed approaches misused in
dealing with problem behaviors and what
you end up with is reinforcing escape
now if you come all the way back to what
the autism spectrum
all about we have a group of people with
a social learning disability who have
problems with social interpretation who
are more likely to be confused by the
social environment so now in addition to
their confusion we give them punishment
contingencies so they want to escape
more makes no sense so the use of
punishment procedures is really
something that we approach in a
minimalist way and as you suggested a
little bit earlier we go after the
antecedents on the equation the
left-hand side of the equal sign is
where we're headed we recognize that we
have to deal with the right-hand side
but we recognize more that the left-hand
side of that equation the antecedent or
the environmental conditions are going
to give us more information and more
strategies to move forward when we talk
about treatment planning and some of the
things that we're going to do with
treatment planning we recognize that we
have functional communication training
where we teach someone an alternative so
in teaching this young man to raise his
hand instead of flipping tables I come
all the way back to the idea that I have
to give him a way of getting my
attention when he needs it before he
flips a table and I'm going to give him
a hard task or something that requires
him to do a written response and I'm
going to be there to coach him to raise
his hand and then I give him the
attention and reduce his demand we
conduct that particular intervention
much in the same way as we would conduct
a functional assessment for a behavior
problem but it's simply a functional
assessment of communication when
behaviors maintained by reinforcement
whether it's positive reinforcement for
social attention or whether it's
materials themselves we give someone
escape from that reinforcing stimulus so
if you're gonna misbehave to get my
attention like that little that little
kid on the video I'm not going to give
you attention when you're misbehaving
but when am I going to give you the
attention when you're when you're not
misbehaving when you're not answering
that's what I'm going to give you plenty
of attention so I want you to learn
there's a contrast call behavioral
contrasts where we say the child's
perspective I behave this way
it's sweetness and light I behave this
way there's no attention this way no
attention yes no I want the attention I
will behave this way we get to apply
reinforcement in this case the
differential reinforcement Percy
to teach an alternative behavior which
might be getting attention in a more
socially acceptable way if the behaviors
maintained by escape
we absolutely identified that we have to
not allow escape to be successful
because it will strengthen the behavior
so what we're going to do alternatively
is we're going to try to make the
environment rich with information so the
child says there's no need to escape I
don't want to escape from this task
because I like being in the task so much
I get help the task is fun the materials
are preferable to me okay
and something that provides a
significant reinforcement for staying in
the game versus leaving the game in the
case of behavior that's maintained by
loss of access to reinforcers we have
access to reinforcement is available
predictably throughout the day and can
be earned okay but not freely accessible
okay we put it on what's called a
contingency for time and when we do that
we also recognize that we're going to
teach children and adults to wait to get
what they want okay just like we all
have to wait for things that we want we
can't have them immediately in most
situations we're going to say that we're
going to teach someone that waiting is a
skill to be acquired when behaviors
maintained by sensory consequences that
are escaped from a sensory event that is
aversive you have to attenuate it ramp
it down those are the headphones or the
earbuds that we talked about before or
you teach people to mitigate the over
arousal effect of that through exercise
systematic desensitization relaxation
training the last point here paired
stimuli is pairing that aversive event
with a highly reinforcing stimulus so
you'd say I'll put up with the aversive
to be in this okay one of my my older
children says that's what happens to
guys when they go to chick flicks
right they really don't want to be there
acting movie but they're gonna eat a lot
of candy and popcorn to put up with it
so it's like okay if that's what you
have to do to put up with it it's it's
okay by me
he is managing pretty well with with
that whole system I don't know how long
it's going to last in though but it's
working for him at the moment when you
have automatic positive reinforcement
which is this is under my control this
is stereotypy this is the hard
not to crack but you have to substitute
something for it
this is the viewmaster example if you
substitute something that is socially
appropriate and more accessible then you
have the opportunity to teach the child
get this in this get your information
this way your sensory information one
way it's more acceptable than this other
way which will cause people to run away
from you or to not want to engage with
you we allow them to earn sensory
reinforcement if necessary and we make
sure that we enrich the environment okay
enriching the environment is a very
important thing to do but in autism
sometimes environmental enrichment means
we have to think like the person with
autism what do they like what are they
looking for if we give them that
information and make it accessible we
have a much better chance of bringing
together what they're looking for now I
recognize that we're also I think
running short on time we're running out
of time so I'm going to leave you with a
little bit of a wrap-up and then if you
want to stick around we'll either talk
or I'll show you a couple of videos the
most important things I want you to take
home from this are that you can
understand why behavior occurs by
looking at the immediate trigger and the
setting events the contingencies in the
environment that operate beyond that
above that at the macro level those
could be reflective of the clients
ability to predict what's about to
happen their physical state like hunger
or illness their ability to to
experience and respond flexibly to
novelty versus things that are more
highly predicted but at the end of the
day you can begin to investigate that in
some very systematic ways one of the
systematic ways is called functional
behavioral assessment and it's more
advanced form functional analysis these
allow you to know they allow you to
generate hypotheses which you then test
as you think about behavior think about
communication behavior speaks behavior
tells you what's going on you then
become the student and your client
becomes the teacher because your job is
to listen and interpret what does that
behavior mean in all likelihood for a
person with autism there's a high
probability that the behavior will be
consistent in its meaning
okay so it generally means something
that the client understands and knows
and you can come to know the last point
about this is interventions come and go
and if you've been in the field like a
lot of the people that the Child Study
Center for a very long time working in
autism all kinds of interventions are
proposed whether that's certain kinds of
diets or it's certain kinds of
activities or hyperbaric chambers or you
know drinking cod liver oil is going to
you know relieve symptoms of autism at
the end of the day you live in you die
on the science okay if there is good
science good evidence that's well
constructed to support certain
intervention practices use it if there's
not you make sure to use it cautiously
but you'll apply an empirical rubric to
that you will engage in hypothesis
testing and analysis in order to
determine whether what you're doing led
to what you wanted to see happen the
outcome that you achieved the final
point in this is it's not a good
intervention if it didn't work you can
always analyze why something doesn't
work but if it's not effective in
bringing about the outcome that you seek
it was not an effective intervention it
needs modification okay you've been very
patient sorry to keep you and run over
any of you that want to stay and I'll
show you a couple of videos I'm happy to
have you but have a great rest of the
day and thanks for being attentive